voilà pour ce reportage alors ça marche
mais encore faut-il qu'il pleuve plus de
trois semaines maintenant sans une
goutte tombée du ciel le thermomètre lui
continue de grimper avec plus de 30
degrés aujourd'hui et ce n'était pas
toujours facile de s'habituer à cette
forte chaleur le reportage à Tours
ce soir dans ce restaurant de l'avenue
Grammont
il fait beau les tours enjaux veulent
sortir alors le chef fera trois services
pour répondre à la demande
malheureusement
quand on a plus de place on a plus de
place sur le stand fraîcheur de cette
boulangerie de la rue de Bordeaux ces
dernières journées ensoleillées ont
accéléré les ventes toutes les 15
minutes
la chaleur un accélérateur pour le
commerce et un bonheur pour les balades
au port de la Creusille les Blaisois
apprécient ces températures estivales
avec parfois quelques nuances ça fait un
peu peur dans le sens où il y aura de la
sécheresse il y aura des incendies il y
aura plus d'eau je pense qu'il fait trop
chaud pour la saison mais ça fait du
bien aussi vu la saison dernière
maintenant on s'habitue quoi mais c'est
pas très bon quoi